a classic symbol of the west
locked up horses just shoulder to
shoulder but about tail to tail george
knapp asked why so many are dying from a
mystery illness in government holding
pens
[Music]
on a nevada range a desperate young
mustang with a broken leg tried but
failed to escape a government roundup
and had to be put down deaths and
serious injuries of wild horses have
become a predictable consequence of the
blm's often brutal helicopter operations
the public rarely sees what happens next
horse is just shoulder to shoulder but
about tail to tail
i mean literally no room to even move
actually he's just a nice boy jerry
reynoldson has spent decades working on
behalf of the mustangs and wasn't at all
surprised when news erupted in late
april that captive horses were dying of
a mysterious illness at a blm facility
in colorado the number of dead horses
kept rising it started out with 67 and
all of a sudden we were up at 85 and
then 100 and the last count i saw and
i'm sure there are more by now that's
been a week ago
was 149 horses
the facility at canyon city relies in
part on prisoners to care for the
mustangs but even with that help
reynoldson says the facility is woefully
understaffed and overstuffed with twice
as many horses as it was built to handle
a direct result of blm's accelerated
program of roundups it just takes one
horse to get sick george
in a crowded condition like that it'll
just spread like wildfire and that's
what's happened when i was there in
august i found a lot of thin horses a
lot of competing horses a lot of
emaciated horses professional
photographer carol walker's iconic
images of horses in the wild are known
all over the world she not only
photographs them but has adopted
mustangs from the canyon city facility
and is appalled by the conditions she's
witnessed there and at other blm pens
like the rest of the public she's barred
from getting anywhere near the facility
but she's learned the mysterious disease
that killed more than 140 horses likely
a version of equine influenza was
allowed to spread because the mustangs
were never vaccinated 10 months after
their capture a violation of blm policy
one of multiple failures documented in
blm's own internal reports this is not a
problem just at one or two facilities
you think it's across the board this is
happening in other facilities and has
been happening for years and the idea
that the blm is now going to round up 23
000 more horses this year where are they
gonna put them at the same time mustangs
were dying in colorado a huge blm
holding pen at wheatland wyoming was
also off limits to the public because of
an outbreak of a disease with an ominous
name strangles 11 mustangs are known to
have died but it's not over blm
acknowledges that more than half of the
2700 horses at wheatland are now
infected jerry reynoldson says the
disease is aptly named basically
strangle themselves they die for lack of
oxygen and
circulation and
dehydration and
it
you just can't imagine a more miserable
way for an animal
to to have to die george despite the
overcrowding and disease at multiple
facilities blm plans to round up a
record number of mustangs in nevada and
across the west this year for carol
walker and others who come to know
individual bands of mustangs and their
bloodlines the sight of horses living
and dying in blm pens is soul crushing
it's the most heartbreaking thing i can
imagine
seeing these horses who had their
families in the wild
and were healthy
and proud and free
and then they're in these filthy holding
pens
with nothing to live for really i mean
they're just standing there and the
light has gone out of their eyes george
knapp 8 news now